hello everybody uh so my name is arman
hezerkani and today i'm going to be
talking to you all about cloud
so to start out my name all right
is that the okay cool so you're talking
about cloud
so first of all my name is armand i'm a
student at carnegie mellon university
and i'm going to be a senior in the fall
i study electrical and computer
engineering and as damian mentioned
i'm the head ta for one of the biggest
computer science courses at that school
um this slide isn't correct but i'm just
going to keep going
so in addition to that i'm an intern at
google
so currently i'm what's called a
developer programs engineer
and what that means is that i write code
every single day
the code i write however is not for
production
so with a code i write doesn't go into
google cloud platform
the code i write is basically to enhance
the developer experience
so i would write a code sample that
would go on github
and developers could see and learn how
to use a specific api and so this is my
second dpe
internship at google this year i'm on g
suite which many of you know and love
and last year i was on gcp but i was
specifically in the context
of edu so i have experience talking to
not only students but also
also a lot of faculty members ctos and
cios of universities
about how to get gcp in a university
and so today i'm going to be talking
about
gcp and i'm going to be answering three
questions for you all
first of all i'm going to answer what is
cloud and so who here has heard of cloud
right we hear it every day we hear all
these new startups spinning up that are
going to be
cloud-based startups and they love that
buzzword right
and we we hear every day that cloud is
going to be very important to our
futures
but a lot of us don't actually know what
cloud truly is
and so i'm going to hopefully clarify
some of the misconceptions
and a lot of the questions that we have
in our heads about
what is cloud in addition to that i'm
going to say what is gcp
so i just introduced cloud and then i'm
going to plug gcp into that mix so how
do gcp's tools
fit into this idea and story of cloud
that i've just told
and lastly i'm going to answer the
question how do i get started
so you all have laptops out that's great
because we're actually going to get
hands-on
and we're going to log into the console
and we're going to spin up a virtual
machine
so everyone's moving you don't need to
get them out yet i will tell you when
for now just sit back relax take some
notes as aaron was saying you could take
out a pen and pencil the old-fashioned
way
but for now we're just going to be
talking and so the first question i'm
going to answer
as i said is what is cloud so before i
answer that question specifically let's
talk about a little bit of history
so i'm going to go through three
different stages of like
how companies and people use computers
and then it's going to end
as you can see in cloud and then we're
going to get into what that actually is
so first of all we're going to talk
about the world as we used to know it
which is when companies were in the
on-premise world
so basically this is back in the day
let's say i'm a startup and i'm spinning
up the newest
like social media uh website let's call
it like
facenotebook.com or something and i have
five users
at that point i have one server sitting
in my closet and i have one person just
managing that server
right everything's fine because i only
have five users the next day though
word spreads and i have a thousand users
and then my website keeps crashing
and i'm like why is that happening and
does anyone know the answer
it's because i only have one server
right and one server's not gonna handle
that traffic
so i have to do something called scaling
and nowadays we think about scaling and
again that's another buzzword that
startups used
love to use but back in the day scaling
was this it was i had to go to a store
buy a brand new computer put it on top
of the other computer in my closet
download code on that do a bunch of
other stuff to add it to my network
and then i could now handle a thousand
users
and that took almost an entire day that
was a huge headache
and so like that was just that that's
basically one of the things that led to
cloud
but so that pain point is what led to
the next thing called time sharing
so we have startups that have these
computers but on the other side of the
aisle we have these huge
companies think like ibm right and they
they have a lot of money they can buy
gigantic sets of computers they don't
need to guess
and say okay i have a thousand users
today what if i have a million tomorrow
and then i'm going to buy that many
computers to basically manage that skill
ibm they could just go out and buy a
million computers right
but what if they over budgeted now they
have like 200 computers they're not
being used
then one smart person said hey let's
rent these out
let's allow other other companies like
these startups
to rent out these computers for certain
amounts of time
so that then it's cheaper for them and
we're making passive income
and so that's how we got to the idea
called time sharing
and then this got more and more popular
and then that just became mainstream it
became very normal for
startups smaller companies to go to
large companies
and rent out their computers for a
certain amount of time
and then after a while these bigger
companies said oh
what if we can make more money off of
this time sharing thing what if we
provided additional services
on top of this infrastructure that we're
selling
and these additional services this suite
of services that was created
is what's called cloud and so i didn't
necessarily get into the details of how
people use cloud
but now i'm going to get into that to
hopefully clarify what cloud really is
going one level deeper
so cloud is oftentimes broken up into
three different like
umbrellas of tools and so the first set
of tools
is what's known as infrastructure as a
service infrastructure as a service
that's time sharing
that is i have a computer and i'm not
using it all the time
so let me sell it for a certain amount
of time to these other companies
i have storage disks let me sell this
infrastructure right it's literally
hardware that you can touch and feel
so i'm selling that and then as i said
these companies said what if we can add
additional tooling
to this infrastructure what if instead
of saying okay i have 10 users today
and then i have 100 users tomorrow and
making the companies
manually scale that on our network what
if we just had a tool that said
hey startups whether you have 10 users
or a million users we will handle that
for you
you just need to write the code for your
website and we will fully scale for you
so that's basically infrastructure plus
a little bit of magic that's what those
star
i throw those stars up there to like
throw a little bit of magic in the
background
right because it's basically
infrastructure with some software
involved
but it's quite magical i like to think
of it that way at least
and then lastly is software as a service
so these are basically tools that you
know
think google docs google drive slides
and sheets
there are also other companies that are
in the software as a service space
like salesforce for example if you've
heard of them
and so this is basically these are the
three different tiers
or three different umbrellas of cloud
so now what is cloud right i basically
just
gave some background then i talked about
the three umbrellas so what is it
in one sentence cloud is a set of tools
that helps you spend less time managing
and spend more time creating
so let me say that again cloud is just a
set of tools that helps you
the developer spend less time managing
and more time being creative as a
developer
so i don't need to hire an entire staff
to scale my infrastructure
i can just pay google a little extra
money
and they'll fully scale for me so i need
to put time into that
i can put time into building new
features talking to my customers
that's what cloud is and so now
what is gcp gcp
is obviously a cloud tool but it's many
things
and so before i get into the specifics
of gcp let me talk about google cloud as
a whole
so google cloud is the mixture of both
gcp on the right and g suite on the left
and so gcp in in a basic sense
is the infrastructure and platform as a
service side of the house
so those are things like like like i
said infrastructure and platform where
you can
run code store data things like that and
then g suite as you all probably know
is things like google docs google drive
that is the software as a service side
of the house
and so within the umbrella of google
cloud this is how we divide things
up on the right in gcp land we have
infrastructure and platform
and on the left we have software today
we're only talking about gcp
but as you all probably know g suite
also has a ton of apis
that you can use to enhance the gcp
experience
and they use a lot of the same consoles
for example and so you should really
look into that as well
so on gcp you can do a lot of things
first of all you can run code so you can
spin up a virtual machine and you can
literally just run
a giant script that'll take a week
instead of running it on your own
computer and worrying about the battery
dying and this and that
you can just put it on a virtual machine
in the cloud or you can deploy a web
application and have the code run on
cloud
you can store data so we have sql
databases we have nosql databases
we have file storage all of these things
i use almost every single day
to build web apps all these tools and
again it's mostly all
fully managed and fully scaled we have
tools for
data migration so this is for like
companies that have
a bunch of data in let's say disks in
some closet somewhere
and they want to get that information
onto the cloud we have tools that allow
people to do that
we have tools for networking so in less
than a minute you can spin up a
worldwide network
literally from here to india i can spin
that up in less than a second
we have tools for networking i mean uh
sorry for monitoring
so let's say you have all these tools in
your cloud in your platform
and you want to monitor how they're
working if one thing crashes let's see
why that happened
we have tools that allow you to do that
we have tools that help you build
internet of things
projects so you should look into iot
core
also we have tools that help
administrators manage this entire
platform because
projects like we're going to see later
on with big companies like
spotify and coca-cola they have a lot of
stuff going on in their cloud so they
need
some way to manage all that we have
tools that help people do that
we have tools to build your own apis
called apiary and other things
and lastly we have tools that help you
build security
and administration into your platform so
you can say okay i have user data
in my sql table i don't my entire
company doesn't need to see what's going
on in there
so you can manage who can see what
within your platform
using the iam and admin tools we also
have some open source tools
like tensorflow which is we have some
sessions on that it's a machine learning
platform
totally open source many other companies
use it as well we have kubernetes as
well as other
open source tools that help with
security and management as well
so now i've gone over what is cloud and
i've talked about what gcp is
so now we're going to talk about how
some companies are actually deploying
these tools
and using them to help them spend less
time managing
and more time creating more so if we
could just play the video now that'd be
great we wanted to make this marketing
campaign for coca-cola something that
every single person in this world no
matter who you are
could participate in the world cup
experience submit your photo
you can be on the pitch at the opening
ceremony
we're talking about three million and a
half images from
over 200 countries different formats
different
users different sources fans could
actually find their photo
to know okay i was here on the flag in
the opening of the world cup
it was a gigantic scale the agency that
was creating the photo mosaic
printed in fabric we recreated the
equivalent digitally
we did not have time to set up an
infrastructure and set up the servers
and configure the machines
by using google cloud platform we went
straight into
building on top of it without that my
first deliverable
would be impossible you have to predict
what the loads are going to be there's a
lot of uncertainty
when you look at a cloud provider like
google the opportunity there is for auto
scaling you don't have to worry about
disaster recovery you don't have to
worry about backup
because it's provided to you as a
service we wanted to send
everyone that had an image in that flag
a notification the very moment the flag
was opened physically in the field we
would have a lot of people doing that
simultaneously
they are not taking turns to use it
so we were monitoring the transmission
on tv
and waiting i remember clearly seeing
these spikes
and just hope please please escape
upscale up
and indeed fundamentally it's down to
one thing and it's one word it's trust
the same infrastructure that powers the
google search engine and search
experience
is what's powering the cloud that
coca-cola is running on
the biggest digital marketing initiative
to participate is like a once in a
lifetime opportunity
i heard someone trying to clap you can
go ahead and clap
all right one more over here okay anyway
so who's heard of coca-cola
right so coca-cola one of the biggest
companies
on the face of the earth put their
biggest marketing campaign
in history in the hands of google and as
you saw it went very very successfully
and so that's just one example and now
we're going to see another one so let's
see how spotify used gcp
to enhance the music experience for
everybody
can we roll the mission of spotify is
really about
being a great musical companion and
making it more personal
it's not going to be the streaming music
experience of the online music
experience it's going to be
your music experience we create the
tools for people to actually
swim in that sea of music data and
find the information that really
corresponds to
why they're there quite a while ago
we've made a decision to focus on data
depending on the complexity of the query
it could take a whole day
sometimes it would have to run overnight
and being able to store
that and process that has been a very
big challenge moving to google's cloud
platform
enabled us to take use of the skill that
google can provide
the reality is it's quite hard to build
great data centers and we saw an
opportunity
to spend our focus elsewhere and that
was really the driver into
google's cloud platform with google
cloud tools we can
rerun the same query and it might take a
few seconds
minutes the less time that we can spend
solving problems that
are already solved like scaling our
hadoop cluster when
google has already figured out how to
scale it for us the more time and energy
we can spend on
turning our data into value and that's
really a game changer for us
when you're talking about a technology
like bigquery when you're talking about
dataflow
you will feel the spotify product evolve
making the user experience great
once you break down the data you realize
that there are
new ones it's not a straightforward path
it's a mosaic
rich beyond the most popular artists
it's a lot more than that
music can transcend boundaries of
language
culture if it moves you then it's there
and it's there forever
[Music]
so spotify another gigantic company that
we all use put their success
in google's hands they used google's
tools to basically
get a bunch of their data from users and
provide tools to their users like
the daily mix or whatever else playlists
that are custom made for you
and they if you heard in the video
basically the cto said
why would we try to solve a problem
that's already been solved
google was building the biggest search
engine in the world
and as a matter of fact they just built
one of the greatest data center or
one of the greatest sets of data centers
in the world so why would another
company put time into doing that when
they could just put more time into
creating
and so that's how companies use gcp
but how are students using gcp that's
what we're worried about today
right so now we're going to go through
some projects that students actually
built
and we're going to see what tools they
used so first
i'm going to talk about a tool that we
found at the university of arizona
at a hackathon called hack arizona so a
few of us were at
the hackathon and we were judging and we
saw this group of students
there's about three students and they
were freshmen and they just got back
from a trip to europe
and they were telling us about the
horror stories of finding tickets
to and from europe if anybody's ever
tried to find tickets to europe as a
student
you know how difficult it is to find
tickets that are within our budget
and they basically wanted to solve this
tool using technology
and so they showed up to this hackathon
and they said how can we build a tool
that will allow
students to find cheap flights to and
from europe
and if you know anything about like
searching for flights
you know that there's an api out there
or a few apis out there
where you can literally scour the
internet for every flight that's out
there
it includes where it's going from and
where it's going to
it includes the price the times all the
information you need
and so they basically queried this api
and now they had a gigantic
data set and a very difficult problem
because parsing
this uh basically it's like a tree right
it's like a tree with nodes of different
places where you're going
and parsing this and trying to find the
cheapest flight
that's what's called the traveling
salesman problem and that is a very very
computationally heavy problem
as some of you may know if you study cs
and so
they thought how are we going to do this
because no one's ever solved this
problem in less than exponential time
and so it's very very computationally
heavy let's just
throw it on google cloud's vms they spun
up
like the biggest and most expensive
virtual machine that we had it had like
16 cores or something it was insane but
they spun it up
and when you go onto this web
application you don't even notice that
it's doing this
gigantic search because of how
strong and powerful google's
infrastructure is and the code that they
wrote was also pretty efficient
and so that's one example of a thing
that we could all use
and we all could have thought of as well
but it relies on gcp
to make it usable to make it something
that we would actually use
and it saves us time next i want to talk
about a team
that was from columbia university they
were basically solved with this problem
which is
how do we allow two people to
communicate if one person is typing
and one person is on the phone and so
the
the problem that they very quickly faced
was what language do these two
users speak to each other and i'm not
talking about like spoken language
i'm talking about one person's writing
the other one's speaking
literally how do we put these two
together and they also
found gcp at this hackathon and this is
what they came up with
so this is a diagram of the stack that
they built and i'm basically going to
walk through what's going on here
so on the top right you'll see twilio
that's another company that builds
an api that allows you to use cell
phones via code
basically and it built it spins you up a
phone number and so you can call you can
text and do a bunch of things from from
the api
on the left we have hangouts chat which
is a google product and then we have
messenger which is a facebook product
those are both chat
messaging apps so let's start with the
right let's start with
how do i allow a user to speak and
turn that into text and send that over
to a chat
room so
so we start with twilio sending
a um request basically to an instance
which is basically a virtual machine or
just like a computer
um on google compute engine so they had
a server running on google compute
engine
that was running a flask server so flask
is a python
framework and it basically accepts this
request from twilio
and now they have audio message they
have an audio file
that they then send to google's speech
to text api
and google this api basically uses
google's deep learning
it's a fully trained model all you need
to do is basically call a method
in your code that says almost literally
turn this speech into text so it does
that
and then it sends the text back and then
now
in this server we have text which is
basically just a string and then we send
that
to another server that's also also
running a flask app but that handles the
text side of this stack
and then once we have the text over
there we send that up to the chat rooms
wherever whoever this person is speaking
to
so now using this api and using uh
the google compute engine instance we
were able to turn
voice into text so now let's go the
other way around
so we get text into the server
and then we send that into the text to
speech api
and if any of you saw the presentation
that sundar our ceo gave
at um i think it was google i o
then you probably saw the fully um like
the speaking robot
they were using this deep learning model
which basically turns text
into very recognizable speech it sounds
like you're talking to a person
and so we call that api which sends us
back this audio
we send that audio to the other server
which sends it to twilio
and will respond on the phone and so now
we have a fully
uh auto like we have a full
communication platform between text
and uh speech so we have a little check
mark there we just accomplished that
check so this team built this in a
hackathon using
our tools and if any of you know about
hackathons which you do
they're usually under 36 hours so it
means that these tools are
pretty easy to use if somebody could
just get it done in under 36 hours
and so we're very proud of this team
they built something really cool and
these were two examples of something
that students built and it's basically
up to you all too
to get these tools into the hands of
students throughout the next year
and we're really excited to see what
other projects we can find from your
work
and lastly how do i get started so now
we're actually going to get our hands
dirty now it's time to take out your
laptops
and as we're going through this demo
they're going to be some helpers
walking around and basically answering
questions if you have them
and in addition to that you each have a
coupon code in front of you
which looks something like
this and on the side of this coupon code
you'll see a little yellow bar with a
number
and i'll talk about that a little bit
later but so
we're right now we're going to do four
things first we're going to log in
then we're going to make a project and
i'll explain what that means
we're going to create a billing account
and then we're going to create a vm
so now i'm going to log on to my
computer and we're going to do all these
things
so if we just get the computer on the
screen please
okay cool so this is my computer um
so first and foremost i would like you
all to log
on to console.cloud.google.com
so i'll type it in with you
console.cloud.google.com
and then just press enter and you'll
come to a page that says access
forbidden
okay that will look a little bit
i'll just come here that will look a
little bit like this but it'll have some
other stuff saying sign up for a 300
credit um it might say that if it's your
first time logging on to the console
but i've already logged onto this so it
looks like this
the first thing we're going to do also
if you haven't logged in just use
like a gmail account so the first thing
we're going to do
is we're going to say select a project
and then now we have all these different
projects
and so what is a project let's say i'm a
company
and or a student and i'm working at a
hackathon and i want to build that
flight tool so within that flight tool
they had an uh a web app running they
had some storage instances running and
they had a few different google
cloud platform resources so the way that
we house that all together
with the permissions and everything is
in a project so it's
quite intuitive a project is a project
so to make a project we click on new
project
and what we what it's asking us for is a
project name
you can name this anything you want and
if you're like incorrect or are not in
the correct format
it'll tell you and then you can change
it but so i'm just gonna
stay with the default and then it's
going to say no organization
that's fine for now and then create
so it's doing right now is it's
basically making my project
it takes a minute because it needs to
propagate through all the systems
but as we wait for that to happen um
again if you have any questions there
are people standing around who can
answer your questions
so feel free to raise your hand if you
need it so
now we have our project as you can see
this is our dashboard
and right now it is fairly empty there
is no sign of any errors for the
whatever it's all empty
right and so the way so as you use it
this stuff will get filled up with
some monitoring and some tools that will
help you see all of your resources at a
glance
but the one thing i'm going to highlight
right now is at the top left of the
screen
so up here we see project info and i can
zoom into this a couple
clicks as well so we have three pieces
of information
the two most important are at the top
and the one most important is right in
the middle
and that is your project id so your
project name
is not universally unique but the
project id
is and so the project id often times
when you're using gcp tools
you'll be asked for it and the way that
you'll find that is you'll just click
on google cloud platform which will
bring you back to the dashboard
you'll make sure that you're in the
correct project and then you'll just
find it right here
so if you ever need if you ever need
your project id you can just go right
there
so next let's hook up billing so
gcp costs money so companies pay us
money
uh to basically use these tools but as
students as we all
as was mentioned before um we have these
free credits
that we can use to use these tools for
free to get started
so these coupons each have a code on the
bottom in the
in uh i guess that's like an orange hue
um
and so the way that you enter these is
you go to
console.cloud.google.com
same as before but you do slash edu
so that's console.cloud.google.com
edu and so you go to this page and you
see that there's a little form
specific to education grants and these
are the ones that we have here
and so what we do is we enter this code
so i'm going to do this live
right now 1900
so we can all enter these together
and then once i'm done entering it
instead of the red we see this
credit amount expiration date and course
so
michael where are you wave to us hey
michael michael's name is on the board
so now we have this uh coupon code
one quick thing oftentimes if you're at
an event and you have these codes and
you're handing them out
people will say oh like this code is
still red even though they're done
typing
the first thing that they probably did
was they just had a typo but otherwise
it could be that they already used the
coupon or they already entered it
and so if you ever need to debug that
problem it's probably one of those two
things they either mistyped it
or they already used that code
and so for country residents i'm just
going to say us
and then please email me updates so
these are not like
very annoying marketing updates they're
actually things specific to education
so i love education and i'm going to
click yes
as you all love education and then i
click accept and continue
so what this does is it creates what's
called a billing account
and so the idea of a billing account
versus a project
are there kind of two different things
so every project
needs a billing account hooked up to it
but i can have one billing account
that's hooked up to several projects so
let's say i
enter my credit card and i have one
project for like a side project i'm
doing and then another
one for a class project i could have
that one billion count tied to these
multiple projects
and so the way that you hook them up to
the actual project
is you click on this drop down menu
right at the top
and then you go down to manage billing
accounts
and then so now we're on the manage
billing accounts
and then up here we see i'll zoom in a
little we see my billing accounts
and my projects right now we want to go
to the projects so that we can specify
what billing account we want to use
so we go to my projects and over here we
see
this is the project that i just spun up
daring diode
yeah really quick
if anyone's having trouble uh when
they're trying to create a new project
and it's saying organization and there's
the red text um what that means without
getting into specifics
um try using your personal gmail account
um some people's school domains like
your.edu account
aren't activated to use gcp and so
use your personal gmail if that's the
case
and then once you've done that if you're
still having issues raise your hand and
we'll come and try and help you
cool yeah and that's also a very good
point michael that's something that a
lot of the people at your school will
also face
we run into this with faculty all the
time and so if if that is an issue that
means that your g suite administrator
so like the it people at your school
didn't allow gcp to be used
in this um in this organization so if
you just use your gmail account
everything will be fine
so we're here and right now this is
already hooked up to the billing account
because i already
had one but for you to add a billing
account you click on this dot dot dot
thing
and you click change billing account and
then you can just pick one so this has
no billing accounts available because
i already have one but you'd click on
that dot dot
you click change billing account and
then you would click the actual billing
account that you want to hook it up to
which would be called michael hemamoto
or something and so now
we go back to our project and we have a
billing account here
and we have our project set up so let's
actually do something in here let's
actually build a resource
so we're going to do what's called
spinning up a vm so we're just going to
create a virtual machine
and for those of you who don't know what
a virtual machine is it's basically like
an abstraction away from an actual
computer
so you all have computers in front of
you and they all have cpus in them
that's actually running the code
so we have a bunch of cpus at gcp but
we don't sell those exactly we sell
what's called a virtual machine
which is running on this actual
cpu so we can have like three or four
vms running on one cpu
and they're kind of separated operating
systems
so we're going to do that first thing
we're going to do is click on the top
left
hamburger menu so this is like if you
ever need
anything you just click on this and it's
probably there this is like
the answer to all of my problems ever
that's not exactly true but i hope it
was um so you're over here
as you can see a lot of the tools i
spoke about earlier like iam and admin
and app engine and storage and all these
things
they're all here so if you ever want to
use one of these tools
you click on the hamburger menu and then
you scroll down to it and find it there
what we're going to do now though we're
going to use compute engine
which is like what shorthand you just
say gce
so you go to compute engine you just
click on that and then
it says compute engine is getting ready
so as you can see there's like a lot of
times when gcp is just kind of
propagating data through its systems and
so that's what it's doing right now it's
just
getting ready for us but once that
happens then we can just get ready
and do that and again i see like people
are continuing to raise their hands keep
doing that
um our helpers are running around
answering questions
so yeah just keep your hand up if you
have a question and they'll get to you
so we are still waiting and waiting
but once it gets ready
we will continue
anybody have a joke
i guess that was kind of a joke nice we
did it
oh you have a joke yeah go for it
why does waldo wear stripes uh
let's give that a round of applause that
was really something
okay so i'm gonna refresh and then see
if that helped so it's still getting
ready we have time for one more joke i
think
anybody oh we got one over here yeah
stand up for us what's your name
[Music]
not going to repeat that one okay
so this is still getting ready let's go
to uh do i have a different project
so is anybody's ready okay cool it's
ready okay so who's
is ready right now awesome that's like a
little bit of the crowd
and then i'm also going to point you to
a tutorial for this later on after this
so if you fall behind you could just go
through that as well
so basically right now we click on
create
and this is basically the form that will
help us create this instance
so the first thing we need to do is zoom
in but then after we're done zooming in
we specify the name of the instance so
i'm just going to leave this as
uh as it is instance one i could make
this
armond's instance so i guess i'm not
going to leave it as tempens
anyway it's called armand's instance now
and then now we select the region which
basically means
where in the world this computer is
actually going to sit
so you can tell it if you if you're in
london and your tool
and all your users are in london and you
want this computer to actually be closer
to them
because of like actual networking speed
then you could spin it up in london
for now i am in uh south i'm not in
south carolina actually
um i want to go to us west so let's go
la and then you could specify the actual
zone which is like
uh one level deeper than region
and then now we click on the machine
type so we can click anything from
micro which is like a very very small
computer all the way up to
wow 96 cpus that is something
so i'm just going to go lightweight and
click one cpu
and i'm not going to deploy a container
engine i'm just going to spin up this
operating system which is a debian
operating system but also what you can
do here is
you can specify a specific what's called
image
so a specific operating system with
certain things installed
so you can specify that and spin up a vm
with all of that
already configured and so for security
courses for example
a lot of times teachers will say hey go
to this virtual machine
it has an old version of some operating
system try to break into it
and so if you have uh like courses like
that at your school you can easily tell
the
professor hey this is an idea that you
might be able to use
and then the rest of it i'm just going
to skip but there's also other settings
that you can set like all down here
and i'm just going to click create so
this actually takes a hot second so i'm
going to
open up a new tab and show you about
that tutorial that i was talking about
so i open a new tab and i go to um
what is it code labs
dot develop let's just google code labs
so it's codelabs.develop
so again codelabs.developers.google.com
and so this page is going to be very
very useful to you so
who are the returning student innovators
in the room awesome
how many of you have used a code lab
awesome so that's
almost everybody so codelabs are
basically tutorials
that step you through how to use and
how to use a specific tool and perform a
specific task so in this case we want to
spin up a virtual machine
so if you type in virtual machine
you can start this code lab so you can
start
create a virtual machine and what this
basically does
starts with an overview and then you go
to setup and requirements
and it basically walks you through
exactly what you need to do
to create a code lab including the
cleanup so like how to delete it
and so these are really good for if
you're holding a session where you you
invite some students and you want to
teach them about a specific tool
i know zeeshan's done this a bunch so i
recommend you all use this tool a lot
and if you fell behind you could easily
come here and uh
continue with the code lab on your own
and so with that
the instance has been created so we
click into that
and now we we have a computer so we can
ssh into it
and what this basically means is just
opens up a console where i'm literally
writing code in the doc
i mean in in the virtual machine and so
it connects
ssh keys to the vm it is connecting
and now i can do anything so i can say
i can make a file called hello world.py
i can go in there and i can say print
oh no print
hello world
save that and then i could say python
helloworld.py and it runs the code
so you can do anything in these
computers you can set up a server on
these computers you can do literally
anything
you can train a model like a machine
learning model on there
so they're very very powerful and then
to close it
you just click x and leave and then now
let's clean this up so we don't want to
run out of our entire hundred dollar
credit
so we want to go to the top right and
just click delete
and that will delete the instance that
we just created and so that's how we
clean up
what we just did and so i recommend that
you tell all of your uh
the people that you're working with to
clean up their projects afterwards
so they're not billed so
that is that cool so that's all for the
demo
so if we could just go back to the slide
deck
so now let's just do a little bit of a
recap so we started out
telling the story of on-prem to cloud we
gave a little bit of history
and kind of tied all the loose ends of
how we actually got here
then we we talked about the three
different umbrellas of cloud
infrastructure as a service platform as
a service and software as a service
then we talked about gcp versus g suite
so we broke up
the infrastructure and platform as a
service under gcp and we said
g suite covers the software as a service
side
we also talked about gcp's tools and use
cases
by going through the different areas the
gcp covers
and wrapping up how both companies and
students
use these tools in meaningful ways and
lastly
as we just did we tried it we actually
opened up our laptops
we walked through the code and we spun
up a virtual machine
so that is all for me i want to thank
you all for coming
i think we have a little bit of time
left so you all can continue working and
trying to finish up that demo that we
just did but i want to thank you all for
listening to me
right on thanks armon we
appreciate it all right everyone we are
back on time
it's very exciting so as we move into
lunch we are eating at the time that we
had planned to eat lunch
at which is very exciting uh you can
actually leave your stuff
in the room if you want we have security
maybe lock your screens
don't just like leave it totally
unlocked but you can leave your stuff in
the room if you want
um you're going to be eating lunch
upstairs same place you had breakfast
you'll be hold on a minute you'll be
eating with real life
google engineers so actually being able
to interact with them
and learn from them there's no assigned
seating
so make sure you sit with people that
look like they're
going to be interesting which i can
assure you they all will be
and lastly uh we will see you in an
hour so ten to one is when you'll be
here be safe upstairs as you eat food
i mean don't run each other over perfect
have we gone
is
[Music]
i